αμόνη της έχωοι για αυτόν έχαμε και τη και την κυβέρνηση μαζί μας και την
προηγούμένοη και ο φίλουμε να των α αγνωρίζουμε αλλά και την νην κυβέρνηση η οποία
είχε εναλλάπει το δύσκορον ουέργον της υλοποίησης σήμερα ν υπήρχει εφυπουργείο αθλητισμού θα δαμεπιο ευκολή
αυτή διοργάνωσε θα ήταν πιο εύκολη η ζωή όλο μας όσον ασχολούμαστα μεόσον ασχολούμαστ με
των αθλητισμό γενικότερα από το απλω το καθημερινώ μέχρι και την λοποίση διαφορών μεγάλων αθλητικών
διοργανωσε διότι είναι άλλον να παίρνει κάποιος ένανατομο την πολιτική ευθύνη και την ηλοποίηση του
προγραμματώς της κυβέρνησης και είναι δεύεν είναι κάτι διαφορετικών να είναι ένα δικετικό συμβούλιον που
αποτελίται από δεκαδόδεκάτομα εθελοντές και πρέπει να τοτονίσουμε αυτό εθελοντές που καμια φορά ρίχνουν και
μεταμεφέρουν την ευθύνη παρακάτω κι χάννεται στην πορεί και στο χρόνο χωρίς να τους κατηγορώ
ενδεχομένος και εκώ να κάνα το δύο πράγμα αλλά πιστεύω κάτινάποσην η δική μου ότι
ο κυπριακός οργανισμός ανθελτισμού με την παρούσαν του μορφή θεωρώ ότι έχει κλείσει των κύκλων
του και απλά το συνδυρούμε για να επικένου εμπαρακάτω αράβαντρέας αν γίνει μια ένα επιτυχημένο
κύρον πάς και το σπέντ ίσως να είναι και εποψήφιος για εφυπουργός αθλετισμόύ αφού θα
είναι ο πρόεδρος ομος ποντίας που διοργάνωσε το μεγαλύτερο ουσιαστικά ίδε στον αθλητιςσμό τες άςμας
γίνειμε επιτυχή δεν εγαιτοποίο διαφέρει δεν είαι κατι το οποίο σκέφτομε εγώ αυτή τη στιγμή
μαζί με την ομάδα που είμαστε ναφωσιωμένι σλά ότεης ουλευτηκες σκεφτες αυτή τη στιγμή είμαστε
να αποείμαστε απαφοσιωμένοι στο ναφέρουμε κεπέρας αυτή τηντράστε ένα θηλητική διοργάνωση είναι μια δέσμευση την
οποία ν έχουμε πάρει μπορεί να την πύραμεσανομοσπν διά όμως αντηλαμβάνεστε η όμωσ πον ιαείναι
άνθρωπή αρακάποιο άνθρωπι έχουμε πίηση κάποιους άάλς